[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es Sommerrollen ich freue
mich schon die ganze Woche drauf denn
das ist ein Rezept was er einfach ist
ihr könnt super zubereiten vorbereiten
mit zur Schule oder zur Arbeit nehmen es
ist sommerlich leicht voll mit frischem
Gemüse und ihr könnt die Sommerrollen
abwandeln wie ihr wollt also ihr könnt
auch sagen ich gucke einfach mal im
Kühlschrank was da ist und packt das
alles rein oder ihr geht gezielt
einkaufen so ein bisschen nach Farben
und so ein bisschen nach Gemüsesorten
ich werde heute die Sommerrollen
tatsächlich mit Garnelen zubereiten ihr
wisst ich mag gerne eigentlich nicht so
gerne aber ich mag sie halt nicht
zubereiten deswegen gibt es gleich ein
paar fertige Garnelen ansonsten wie
gesagt einfach einfach reinpacken was
euch lieb ist ich mache jetzt erstmal
eine herzhafte Version und dann sogar
noch süße Sommerrollen denn die finde
ich auch sehr lecker und ich finde das
ist einfach was erfrischendes leckeres
was man so aus der Hand essen kann kommt
immer gut an hier habe ich jetzt schon
mal die Zutaten und zwar braucht ihr
dafür Reisblätter die bekommt ihr in
asiatischen Supermärkten oder auch in
gut sortierten Supermärkten dann habe
ich hier noch 100 Garnelen die sind
bereits gekocht und eingelegt die gibt
es beim Feinkost eine Avocado eine rote
Paprika Gurke zwei Karotten hier ein
paar Glasnudeln dann etwas frische
Kräuter hier einmal Kresse Koriander und
Minze und zum Einrollen gern auch noch
Rucola ich habe jetzt hier die
Glasnudeln auch schon mal fertig
zubereitet das heißt ihr nehmt einfach
die Glasnudeln und übergießt sie mit
kochendem Wasser und lasst sie einfach
ein paar Minuten stehen die werden dann
ebenso schön weich und durchsichtig und
dann können diese aus dem Wasser
rausfischen und sie sind sozusagen
fertig das ist so der Sattmacher da drin
weil alles andere ist ja praktisch
frisches Gemüse und ich muss sagen
Sommerrollen sind ja eigentlich so
aufgerollter Salat dann nehmt ihr am
besten die Zutaten und schneidet sie in
feine Streifen also bei der Paprika
mache ich das jetzt zumindest so
und die Karotten die Hobel ich in Julien
Streifen weil ich finde so Karotten die
sind ja auch sehr hart und dass man die
eben gut essen kann wie in so einem
Salat eben lieber schön fein hobeln
soll ich meinen Paprika hautentferner
rausholen
und dann ist die ganze weiße Haut weg
[Musik]
und bei der Gurke hier nehme ich auch
das Kerngehäuse weg weil es sonst zu arg
wässert
[Musik]
bei der Karotte nehme ich jetzt einfach
die V-Hobel mit diesem Julien Einsatz
es geht ein bisschen schneller als mit
dem Messer
und die Avocado halbieren
[Musik]
dann den Kern rausnehmen
dann kann jetzt gefüllt werden alle
Zutaten liegen bereit und ist eigentlich
auch so was geselliges muss ich sagen
das kann man auch gerne mit mehreren
Personen machen indem das reisblatt und
zieht es einmal durch das Wasser einfach
kaltes Wasser nehmen
so ein paar Sekunden einwirken lassen
und wenn ihr ganz schnell arbeiten wollt
dann könnt ihr das jetzt praktisch so
machen dass ihr immer fünf sechs Blätter
nacheinander durchzieht und vor euch
auslegt und dann könnt ihr so eine
richtige
Quad Arbeiten machen hier
Fließbandarbeit
und dann legt ihr euch die ganzen
Zutaten eher hier so mittig hin so in
den Bereich einfach alles was ihr mögt
und am besten die Zutaten die ihr außen
sehen wollt so ein bisschen nach unten
da können das nämlich auch schön
dekorativ anrichten
ich glaube ich versuche mal so eine Art
Regenbogen so ein bisschen Farbspiel
hier Karotten
dann die Paprika
Gurke
ich muss sagen dass ich die frischen
Kräuter am schönsten finde
Minze ist so mein Highlight aber ich
packe natürlich auch Koriander rein weil
es reingehört aber nicht so viel
denn ich mag nicht so viel Koriander
auch wenn er gesund ist
und Rucola
ja ich glaube das reicht ich glaube die
Kresse die streue ich später drauf und
dann packt ihr praktisch beide Seiten
zack
und zack hier rein
und dann aufrollen ich glaube ich
arbeite nicht auf einem Holzbrett das
klebt mit so arg
nimmt gleich einen anderen Teller
aber es geht
und dann habt ihr eure sommerrolle
[Musik]
ich rolle jetzt hier die Sommerrollen
mal noch fertig und mache auch jetzt ein
paar ohne Garnelen denn bei uns mag
nicht jeder Garnelen und werde euch dann
die Zutaten zeigen für verschiedene Dips
denn da gibt es natürlich noch einen Dip
dazu denn so muss man sagen schmeckt das
ganze einfach nach Gemüse und Glasnudeln
aber mit den Dips darin
das ist dann lecker das wird sehr lecker
ich finde Erdnusssoße ist sehr lecker da
gibt es auch schon Rezept auf meinem
Kanal und heute gibt es aber mal eine
andere Soße
[Musik]
für die süß saure Chilisauce nehme ich
100 Gramm braune Zucker 4 Esslöffel
Reisessig 300 Gramm Wasser den Saft
einer Limette zwei rote Chilischoten
etwas Ingwer eine Knoblauchzehe einen
Esslöffel Stärke zum Binden und Salz und
Pfeffer es gibt da erstmal den braunen
Zucker in einem Topf und lasst ihn hier
schön karamellisieren so bei mittelhoher
Hitze
und dann kann ich in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Chilischoten
fein hacken und den Ingwer reiben und
die Knoblauchzehe auspressen
[Musik]
hier beim Zucker jetzt gut aufpassen
dass er nicht verbrennt und sobald er
dann karamellisiert ist also wenn er
hier so schön flüssig ist könnt ihr dann
den Reisessig dazugeben aber bitte
vorsichtig sein denn das ist sehr heiß
da bildet sich dann auch immer gern mal
so ein Kloß das praktisch der
zuckerbrocken aber das macht gar nichts
denn durchs aufkochen geht der auf jeden
Fall wieder weg ein bisschen Wasser
lasse ich jetzt hier noch übrig das
lasse ich hier aufkochen und gebe auch
schon mal die
Knoblauchwürfel die Chilischote und den
Ingwer dazu
also bei mir schmeckt die Soße gleich
schon sehr Ingwer lastig wenn ihr
irgendwann nicht so sehr mögt dann macht
einfach ein bisschen weniger rein oder
lasst ihn weg aber so ein bisschen
Ingwer sollte schon rein und jetzt hier
noch Salz und Pfeffer dazu und
Limettensaft und dann erstmal kochen bis
sich der Zucker gelöst hat
und dann gießt ihr das stärkerwasser auf
das bindet die Soße und lasst sie dann
so ungefähr drei bis vier Minuten
einkochen dann ist sie fertig kann
umgefüllt werden und wir können gleich
wenn die Soße abgekühlt ist die
Sommerrollen genießen
bin schon richtig gespannt
da habe ich jetzt hier meine fertige
Soße die habe ich bereits hier rein
gefüllt am besten bereitet ihr auch erst
die Saucen zu und später die
Sommerrollen die ganz frisch und ich
habe mich noch eine Erdnuss sesamsauce
da habe ich eine real gemacht und auch
das Rezept auf meinem Blog das könnt ihr
euch gerne separat anschauen die ist
nämlich auch richtig lecker die so
bisschen mit Sesam Paste und eben dann
noch diese Chilisauce was ich jetzt
machen werde bevor wir gleich probiert
ich schneide die jetzt einfach noch ein
bisschen auf so
und richte nämlich hier so an
und dann darf der Tolga kaum zum
probieren
[Musik]
hi togga
man muss ja schon oder kann ja schon
sagen du und
Elli ihr seid so unsere
asia-spezialisten Spezialisten ja
richtige Fans und ich liebe ja
Sommerrollen aber ich finde
so nett ganz ästhetisch muss ich sagen
die sehen so aufgeschnitten schon schön
aus ja
da kann ich hier direkt
die Soßen nämlich probieren mit dem mit
dem Sommerrollen also nimm dir ruhig ich
richte so lange fertig an von hier
nehmen wir ach komm ich geb dir hier
eine gell mit Garnele ja gerne danke
schön
so ich probiere die Soße
beide gleich ja
[Musik]
und
der Torge hat mir nämlich auch mal
erzählt das praktisch Sommerrollen so am
Tisch gemeinsam gemacht werden gell ganz
frisch
die richten alles schon vorher an nur
die Rollen die werden dann direkt am
Tisch gemacht und dann hat man das bei
der Unterhaltung heute mal schön dabei
eigentlich wie so ein Raclette-Abend ja
dass man so vorher alles gemeinsam
vorbereitet mit immer nur die Mama
allein und dann hat man so alle Zutaten
und hat so Schälchen Wasser für die für
das Reispapier und fertig und dann kann
man hier schön Sommer Rollen genießen
die sind super lecker ja ich habe auch
schon eine Probleme
Vietnamesen ich habe meine hier vorne
nämlich noch
aber die ist mir dann ich habe sie
weggelegt und dann ging sie auf
die Ella kam auch schon rein und sagt
hier rechts sehen schön asiatisch
[Musik]
stimmt das hatten wir schon mal
lecker
ich bin kein Fan von Erdnuss echt
schlecht aber na gut also nicht viel
drin nur zwei Esslöffel und der Rest ist
Sesam ist auch Teil drin und viel
Sojasauce vielleicht ein bisschen zu
viel Sojasoße aber ich finde die Würze
gut für die Sommerrollen ja und ich
würde jetzt auch noch süße Sommerrollen
zubereiten aber ich würde sagen ich
schließe dieses Video hier heute ab und
die süßen Sommer Rollen die kommen dann
morgen online da haben wir so ein
eigenständiges aber zwei Videos
hintereinander das richtig hier wird
eine Premiere also ja asiatische Rezepte
hier dass ihr wenn ihr das Video
anklickt die herzhaft machen könnt und
morgen dann die süßen und wir können ja
zum Beispiel auch die Zutaten schon
posten dann können die Zuschauer nicht
morgen direkt die süßen Sommerrollen
mitmachen ah ja können wir machen oder
ja super also viel Spaß beim Nachkochen
ist anders viel Spaß beim Zubereiten die
Rezepte findet ihr in meiner App oder
auf sallys-blog.de viel Spaß dabei bis
zum nächsten Mal tschüss Chris und ihr
könnt ja mal schreiben was so eure
lieblingsfüllung ist bei Sommerrollen
und welche Soße
ich finde es auch voll interessant wenn
man da mal Frucht rein macht ja also
ein Stück Mango
oder so ein bisschen Lachs
Avocado
wir probieren noch mal eine andere
Version aus wenn ihr möchtet schreibt
gerne in die Kommentare dann machen wir
mal was richtig abgefahren leckeres
tschüss